osteoporosis is a very important problem
for women it occurs much earlier in life
in women and with a much greater
frequency than it occurs in men and we
don't really understand completely the
factors that put women at greater risk
women who suffer a hip fracture have
about a 20% chance of dying in the first
year after a hip fracture nearly 50% of
women over the age of 50 will have some
sort of osteoporosis related fracture in
their lifetime
in 2002 Women's Health Research at Yale
funded a project in which we asked the
question whether dietary protein was
good or bad for your bones most of the
work before that time had suggested that
dietary protein was bad for your bones
because at least calcium from your bones
with the pilot funding provided why
women's health was searched at Yale we
went back and looked at this question
using sophisticated biochemical
techniques and found that in fact
increasing dietary protein within the
range of normal actually improved
calcium absorption from the intestine
and led to an increase in levels of
hormones in the blood that are good for
your bones
this pilot project that we received in
2002 that led to our current studies
examining the effect of a protein
supplement on bone health and women has
really changed the field in terms of its
opinion about that particular nutrients
effect on the skeleton those findings
allowed us to apply for and achieve
funding support from the National
Institutes of Health and the US
Department of Agriculture that have led
us to do a large clinical trial asking
the question whether an older women and
men who naturally consume low levels of
dietary protein supplementing their diet
with a small amount of protein improves
their bone health
so both in terms of the waste the
scientific community views dietary
protein as well as its possibility as a
treatment for osteoporosis I think our
work has made a major impact
you